ciao una mattina mia madre decide di
farmi uno scherzo e decide di svegliarmi
con una trombetta per la bici suonando
mana nell'orecchio inutile dire che
stava saltato dal letto lo ero buttato
giù non tutti i santi del calendario che
non ha buttato di una madre
ecco cosa di buono che non gli era
inserito che è stata corretta e le zone
recondite ciao ragazzi ben tornati alla
nuova puntata di vita buttata il tema
della puntata di oggi è pesce d'aprile
per un tema così importante ho pensato
di invitare all'interno degli studios
the casa mia una persona che in realtà
mi è stata raccomandata cioè io me lo
ricordo quando arriva tipo sei anni
adesso invece un teppista ed è uno dei
migliori amici diciamo di mio cugino è
di mio fratello uno di quegli amici che
ti porta in galera il presente rashad
bell non devi essere timido parte dal
presupposto che uscendo non ha mai visto
un video
però non ho idea di cosa fosse ma
infatti lo sapevo che tu eri di como il
nostro povero guardarlo ora noi
ascolteremo degli audio legate agli
scherzi e mi ha detto enrico che in
passato avete fatto delle cose da non
raccontare esatto ti dico con le puoi
raccontare tutte sappi che io alcune di
queste non le monte rosa c rimanere male
rimango fuori non in galera perché altra
parte non subito dire che cosa si dicono
che ha trasferito da poco avevo due
confini e hanno ben deciso
che io non c'ero di girarmi stars al
contrario ma non si parla solo dei
piccoli oggetti si parla di tutto il
letto la scrivania la porta avevano
scardinato da quartieri avevano
rimontato al contrario perché lì di mi
abbiano in mente la cosa cioè al tempo
delle convivenze facciamo un cappello
introduttivo che ci crediate o no
enrico era scene si sono conosciuti in
chiesa quindi a marco poi è anche
gianmarco è vero prima di bruciarla in
realtà però di base si sono conosciuti
in chiesa una volta andavano in questi
ritiri spirituali dove loro tutto
facevano tranne che per pregare è
attualmente quella data seneca dalla
stanza tre persone che avevano chiuso
fuori dalla nostra stanza ok
noi ovviamente ci dobbiamo vendicare
vagliando sempre peggio
siamo entrati nella stanza loro passando
dai balconi ma che piano e netta al
secondo piano ma va bene casta
volumetrico metalba wind river dava al
quarto piano
quindi siamo entrati nella loro stanza a
un certo punto ci siamo resi conto che
loro erano andati via dalla nostra
stanza abbiamo preso tutti i mobili gli
abbiamo alzati di veto e li abbiamo a
casa stati tutti nella nostra stanza che
era una stanza che era un corridoio per
due persone tra tutti i filetti tutti
sti armati a cagliari dove gulf riletti
abbiamo lasciato dentro la stanza
soltanto il telefono
lino mezzo riusciamo a staccare che
provenzano che sempre in ha però non ci
riuscivo a home e questi sono quelli
attuali dentro 90 non ci stava niente
non ci trovato veramente niente
scusate ma io mi chiamò per farmi i
treni per stamattina
ma la cosa bella perché mentre tipo
spostavamo mobile davanti alla stanza
del prete due ladri importante le carte
riguarda soltanto noi immobili e poi
chiude la porta ed un remo lanter detti
per qualche secondo e poi coltivavamo
perché non ha le forze di affrontare sia
beh era esasperato e e restavano dante è
rientrato in camera fa tutti io ti prego
e ciao ciao bello io abbia mai fatto
l'ho fatto a mia sorella chi sia perché
serviva un documento di nascita una
scuola ogni ricordo e con mia madre ho
modificato anch'io per il fattorino
sorella fosse data da mia madre
forse finissi che era stato adottato il
genio senza un cuore questo ragazzo
mammamia rea questa è una persona
orribile ayew l'unica cosa che mi
ricordo al momento l'ho fatta però per
punire una persona era successo l'undici
settembre è questo qui in classe se
nasceva una cosa di così vaste e sono
morti io mi giro e siete affatto sai su
un aereo c'era mia madre e lui è morto
sull'aereo
ed è morto però per punirlo mi ha
chiesto scusa ma in realtà gli dicevo
non è morta però è che vi scusa delle
persone che ho offeso perché non sapesse
parlare inglese
ospite lo scherzo più brutto ho ricevuto
che hanno fatto i miei amici come un
bambolotto siamo andati a fare un
weekend e in una casa in campagna di una
mia amica per due giorni mi hanno
torturato con questo bambolotto
facendomela trovare ovunque nonostante
fossero passati due giorni quindi
pensavo questo nati ormai ne avesse
abbandonato quindi lasciata loro invece
hanno chiamato nel fratello e la non so
come dato a mio fratello quando sono
tornata da sera quindi a casa l'ho
ritrovato nel letto di casa mia che
stava lì che mi guardava contestando che
scendeva dalla bocca la paura per
raccontarlo questo studio 6si
strafelicissimo non tanto perché era un
horror morivo perché il [ __ ] muore
tempo per quella non troppo vera faccia
pure un pezzo di cordone ombelicale
attaccato perché sarebbe ha ricevuto nè
un posto da villa saporiti mio fratello
chi sei una scorsa della mia cabina
armadio ora le due di notte in centro
mentre si è inteso qualche modo devono
restare i botti così niente però dico sì
teatro tachimetro del mio stile ma
inventiva noi fatto d'arme l'ansia e
l'avevano racconta nostro incontro del
malato
io mi sono sentita male e 30 a piangere
e le rimesse interazione che spartire
fratello uscire formaggio club che
questo qui c'è il pianto di un bambino
neonato che proviene dalla tua cabina
armadio
riazzino alzavo youtube ma noi oppure mi
prendeva il motto rendevo e con un
lanciafiamme entano dentro il mio
fratello per lanciarmi nella tua stanza
senza cielo 10 del comodino c'è il
lubrificante legge reale e quindi di
entrare con lubrificante scivolava
allora lo scherzo chi è che io abbia mai
fatto è stato a due ragazzi miei
compagni di stanza in america per due
settimane più grandi di me di tre anni
avevo 14 praticamente per due settimane
mi hanno bollinata trattandomi malissimo
usando il mio profumi vestiti senza
chiedervi nulla e allora ho deciso che
ogni viaggio di ritorno dovevano pagarla
ti dico solo che ho dato loro della
cioccolata lassativa un quadretto
bastava per uno stitico e ne hanno presi
tra testa ma io lo sapevo perché era del
ingorde assurde quindi sapevo ne
avrebbero mangiato parecchio e niente
che dire hanno superato ore io avevo in
mente di fare uno scherzo insieme
all'amica noi dobbiamo cioè non erano
scriverà la scommessa cioè chi perdeva
non mi ricordo che la sconfortante non
ho perso io gioco a prendersi un
sonnifero e urla stati voti magica del
dg sveglio di questa persona ma l'hanno
fatto certo per il risveglio è stato
un distretto di sabari esaltato le
tagliate c'è un gol
io nella vita non ho fatto tanti scherzi
ma le ho fatto solamente uno palmiotto
alle ragazze è praticamente io ho
comprato su amazon
sulla carta per fare tatuaggi film che è
già stampato sopra la faccia del mio
ragazzo e una scritta ti amo e poi il
nostro super non è imbarazzante che
voglio tenere segreto o finto di essere
andata ad una festa e senza ma chi l'ha
detto ovviamente essere ubriacata e di
avergli fatto se avessimo fatto fare un
tatuaggio in casa
io ho fatto vedere in tatuaggi che sono
veri con la sua enorme faccia sulla mia
coscia beh tu hai hai fatto dei nomi
tatuaggi facciamogli vedere perché sono
dei tatuaggi abbastanza adulti possiamo
dirlo
fai gli ultimi sono buffi di one piece
ovviamente fango q e questa città ecco
lo ha detto chiaro se il vice per
rilevare un secondo eco auto
naruto stai morendo al mare una volta io
non era un tatuaggio che con una ragazza
conquistavo lei teatro aumentata in una
posizione che mi permetteva di
divertirmi con la crema e gli disegnare
la sagoma di un pene che uscivano dal
play non è così quando ti svegli o che
ovviamente voci allevato le cose hanno
angelo colta affrontato testo pene che
rapportate come se si fosse addormentato
nel signore bene perché poi la camera
darà pure un po sciolto e quindi sembra
pure un po la vita brutta la chiave
della felicità in un fidanzarsi con te
mentre tu sei fidanzato però da quanto
un anno e otto mesi relazione più lunga
sappi che questo video lo vedrà bianca
[Musica]
luigi vii ins econda di iscrivervi tu
intanto intrattieni che faccio lo
scherzo più bello che abbia mai fatto
involontariamente sia stato ai miei
genitori quando stanno la fa da che sono
nata il primo aprile
io scherza ancora più bello l'ha fatto
mia sorella sempre i miei genitori
due anni dopo nascendo anche lei il
primo d'aprile
va beh enrico è mio padre sono nati il
13 maggio tutti e due
ciò familiare in abituato senato 20
ottobre bilancia ascendente bilancia e
non solamente cosa voglia dire però ma
non è tutto
peso forma tu non sei la bilancia mila
morti mi son svegliato che ho fatto gli
auguri alla silva non sapendo che fosse
di compleanno set e non sia in questo
mondo in una volta citofono lui chi è
guglielmo guglielmo chi al telefono con
gabriele anche credo e dico al telefono
con la porta aperta mi raccomando mi
porti il pacco e mario aslam son certo
arriva da me ne sono dimenticato come
hai fatto e dimenticate
solo detto che aveva un piede fuori
allora io propongo di fare una cosa
siccome veramente qua sta diventando
l'asilo l'asilo vado a prendere uno
stipendio per aver fatto il baby sitter
per un'ora questi due altre non potevo
vederlo io direi di prenderci una pausa
altrimenti facciamo il signore degli
anelli solamente scritto ormai capito
così è diventata questa sera
ma è più basso che mi vogliono rito è un
po fattosi ha sorriso ci prendiamo un
momento di pausa la settimana prossima
possiamo la seconda parte purtroppo
persi ciao ciao
si può fare meglio ora io direi ci
prendiamo una pausa o che andiamo a
prendere un pochino di pesce ok che
sembra veramente molto per il bene
vostro per il bene del mio io direi di
prenderci un altro momento di pausa
perché qua ci stanno terry e maggie che
veramente stanno scavando nella bassezza
dello humour cioè il primo bene ci
vediamo la prossima settimana nel
frattempo vi invito a iscrivervi a
commentare qua sotto e soprattutto ad
attivare la campanella in modo da non
perdervi quella che sarà la seconda
meravigliosa puntata di questo tema e
salutato ciao tu lo fai
certo che cos'è un affare quanto quanto
sei giovane contenute in note pari a 31
anni da bar angelo 25 in realtà un 25
del giornale